hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wie heute zu einem neuen
video ihr durftet mir bei twitter wieder
ganz viele videos einsender den hashtag
luca reagiert und das habt ihr zahlreich
getan deswegen reagiert darauf ja ich
habe hier in der lippe irgendwie
irgendwas ist da rot oder angeschwollen
ich habe habe ich mich gemacht ich habe
wir fangen an
ähnlich einem böses was mir dieser
flasche gleich passiert ja okay da
jemanden luca zettelchen auf eine
flasche drauf klickt die flasche weg und
tritt danach noch schön auf dem luca
zettelchen rum
das ist doch mal eine tolle erste
einsendung danke für deine einsendung
ich habe hier eine ganz akkurat antwort
für die ich finde das hat ganz gut auf
den punkt gebracht
warum schickte mir sowas ein nein ok
stopp stopp stopp stopp stopp das ist
nichts denn freunde stein hat mir bis
dahin neues video zu geschick ab
jäger ist also als wenn tomatensaft
nicht schon genug wäre da einfach besser
pause was und was soll ich denn jetzt
machen stellen was was beim nächsten
fantreffen kriege ich jetzt apfelsaft
zugesendet oder was die nächsten male
wenn ich irgendwie sah geschickt mir
videos zu kommen dann nur noch apfelsaft
oder war sich jedenfalls auch in seinem
hofladen kommt als kommentare nur noch
apfelsaft stellen und zerstört mein
leben oder stan kannst mich einfach mal
ein video zu senden wo du sagst pizza
oder so dann kriege ich nur noch pizzen
zu gedenken
das wäre tatsächlich sehr cool trotzdem
danke für deine 1 sendung habe ich hoffe
dass mit apfelsaft jetzt nicht so wie
die mit tomatensaft das was sie da
gerade macht dass ich glaube das geht
jetzt nicht gut habe ich ja gesagt ich
kann allen wurzel baum
doch david
es hat jetzt ein neuer trend immer wenn
ich sage ich ich die videos unter hecken
oder reagiert ist immer ein video dabei
wie eine toilette gezeigt wird seid ihr
bescheuert dass hier erstmalig über
spenden börsen treten spiegel listen
fenster das ist hier sind auch lampen
tatsächlich ergebnis geführt dass videos
bei der angry birds kinofilm premiere im
stand und sie ist ja schon mal in einem
lokal reagiert der zuschauer video
kommentare video dings vorgekommen wo
sie auf kommando gerüst hat und er kann
wieder an und weise sicher kommt jetzt
die hat halt gerückt und ich hab dann
geräumt und dann wieder und ich und ich
finde meinen blick am ende auch sehr
sehr attraktiv da sieht man wieder wie
toll ich gucken kann kein problem ich
kann nicht auf kommando holzen
aber das kind das unglaublich süß judoka
ich wollte einfach mal sagen wie geil
bistra voda ich danke man noch weiter
mit den videos ich mache einer videos
vielleicht kannst doch noch die ich
nicht mag oder dinge die ich mag dinge
die ich an dem kurs sind macht halten
denn wie das ist wirklich ein cooler typ
und größe kollege und ich danke für
deine netten kommentare ja danke viele
leute haben mir seitdem luca packen
geschenke video ausgesagt dass sich sehr
um das papier
die aktion und meiner fans gegenüber mir
belangen die sache ist freunde das ist
mein humor dass ich auch so was so
reagiere und wenn ich jetzt jemand wäre
der sage danke man ich liebe dich dann
würde ich babys beauty palace heißt und
das bin ich nicht weil luca parteien
geschenke video kamen voll viele leute
in den kommentaren an um einen super wie
undankbar und biss wie du damit umgehst
freunde ich kann nicht neben dingen drei
minuten was zu sagen ich mag die leute
die mir die sachen geschenkt haben die
haben mich ja live gesehen und haben
gesehen wie ich mich darüber gefreut
habe aber es waren so viele sachen und
ich hab halt auch nicht den ganzen tag
zeit um mich zu sammeln zu widmen und
ich bin keine vollzeit youtuber und
freunde es tut mir leid so rübergekommen
und bei dem fan geschenkt dass es so
wenig undankbar wäre aber mein gott ich
keine andere youtuber die schmeißen
entsteht direkt weg also wieder einmal
so gemein zu dir ist sag ich jetzt mal
was positives über die banken also da
wäre doch nein also das finde ich geil
wenn du bist besonders gute und dann
hart
danke für diese neue animationen ich
habe mich wirklich sehr darüber gefreut
hat er mich niemals am ende einfach
nochmal drei konkrete fragen mit rein
ich weiß nicht ob ich den warum wir
dabei bin also ich selber hätte
ultrabook ich habe noch keine infos dazu
gekommen ich war auch in minecraft mero
nicht mit dabei deswegen habe ich keine
ahnung ob sie mit alle noch mögen ich
meine bei mir kommt einmal in der woche
minecraft also ich würde es verstehen
wenn ich sagen kann du bist kein
minecraft kanal mehr aber ich würde mich
freuen wenn ich mit dabei sein wäre
würde ich fühle mich zu fragen
das ist das ist okay bahro ist meiner
meinung nach das einzige coole minecraft
projekte es gibt sicher ich kann nicht
an und dann zehn hätten abc- wie viele
minecraft projekte es gibt insgesamt und
ich finde ist das einzige worauf ich
mich persönlich wirklich feuer
deswegen finde ich sehr cool wenn ich
mit dabei bin habe ich kannte die frage
konkret nicht beantworten luca und zwar
habe ich eine frage ob du schon recht
ging an geschaut hast du also das ist
relativ witzig und zwar so dass erste
zweite dritte mal ruhig racing geschaut
hab was mit meinem cousin und mit meiner
oma und meine oma war die ganze zeit so
oft kommt das ist ja so schlimm muss
oder man gesehen und ich gesagt das ist
eigentlich alles und schauspielerei ist
und dann war sie voll der wrestling fan
und ich wollte mal fragen an eine
bettwäsche rauskommt die bettwäsche
läuft halt nicht direkt über den
das macht zusammen meinem netzwerk
studio 71 ich weiß nicht ob die da nicht
in die pötte kommen oder woran das alles
liegt aber bettwäsche ist immer noch in
konkreter planung kommt vielleicht
irgendwann mal sonst nicht selber in die
hand ich meine es ist halt einfach nur
geil zugleich ihre wäsche da gerade an
und dann stellt einfach anstatt den
stellen wieso habe ich eigentlich schon
auf meiner passion statt reden einfach
kleines marlies hennig ultra coole
deswegen bettwäsche will ich unbedingt
noch realisiert auch vielleicht bald
nochmal in deinem schöpfen rabatt aktion
stattfindet kann mich jetzt erstmal
nicht so viel zu sagen
die nächste größere aktion die geplante
ist der launch von diesen beiden t shirt
der irgendwann im mai stattfinden wir
zusammen noch mit einem kissen und
werden die sachen hin
immer wenn ich ihm was die hinschmeißen
fällt alles von meinem schreibtisch
runter wenn die sachen in den shop
kommen dann gibt es halt wieder
irgendwie 1000 bis 2000 unterschriebene
sticker von mir mit dabei und danach
machen wir vielleicht aber eine
rabattaktion aber das ist auf jeden fall
erstmal die nächste größere geplante
aktion an dieser stelle werde ich das
video meine damen und herren wenn es
euch mal wieder gefangen hat das j
zuschauer videos reagiert habe dann
zeigt mir mit einer bewertung shop mit
40.000 likes für einen neuen park ihr
seid spitze und bleibt immer fresh folgt
mir auch instagram weil da bin ich in
letzter zeit aktiver als ich sonst immer
war und ich will vor dem video desktop
die eine million aber erst noch
instagram knacken weil dann steht also
ganz cool so ein m
das ist das ist cool